nous sommes en danger il faut que ça
s'arrête
juste en face du parc depuis sept ans et
et donc c'est très compliqué depuis le
17 mai suite à décision absurde qu'elle
était prise de l'église les jardins
d'eole pour les toxicomanes
on habite ici depuis l'année 78 jamais
vu quelque chose comme ça
déjà ce qui l'attend pas bon mais là
depuis qu'on a des problèmes avec
staline
avec le parquet hall la vision qu'on
avait déjà l'habitude de cohabiter
puisque c'était le nord-est parisien a
déjà été investi par par ce type de
population depuis un petit moment mais
disons que là la preuve a été vraiment
concentré sur le jardin et donc en tant
que livre n jardin toutes les rues
adjacentes ont été forcément impactées
je sors de chez moi
le plus sur les courts châtains guinée
vient de nanan fin de trimestre 55
mètres carrés maximum et je rentre chez
moi
kouakou fiéni jeune champion olympique
est la troisième étape très mal géré le
fait de sortir de chez soi c'est déjà
une angoisse je me vois j'ai des enfants
en bas âge on peut trajet de l'école à
la maison par exemple c'est tout de
suite si on avait que j'ai vu la
traversée s'est tout de suite en chozen
notre choix par d'une mauvaise rencontre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi je suis inquiet donc moi je vais
chercher ma femme pour l'hiver 2010
metro tout ça c'est quelque chose qui
n'arrive pas bon on n'en peut plus même
quand on va faire nos courses on se fait
agresser sur les trottoirs parce que le
problème c'est que
ce qu'ils nous demandent de l'argent
donc tous sont choqués on craque et ils
sont extrêmement intéressants et nous
apprend par le bras ils nous lâchent pas
ils nous suivent sur formelle et ça
devient insupportable
toxicomane il peut devenir venez violent
parce qu'ils ont besoin que le dos ah
bah ça peut toujours être deux
agressions permanentes pas l'choix nuit
détruits
tout annuler et on peut pas dormir on
subit également des gens qui viennent se
shooter dans nos cages d'escaliers alors
que normalement on est sécurisé avec des
sa paire par les gens les enfants même à
7 heures du matin qu'on est moins à
l'école se font agresser mais ce qui
devient surtout insupportable c'est dans
nos habitations
parce que maintenant on n'ose même plus
et sans nos poubelles g et law
n'entretient rodet nous notre quartier
[Applaudissements]
face à ce silence des pouvoirs publics
nous devrons tenir rodez d'où notre
porte
rodez nous nos trois quartiers moi et me
suffisait de lameilhé hiver
et le commissariat
il est différente les abords des écoles
ça fait d'oublier ces gens moi pour les
alertes
ça fait deux mois que les alertes ont
quotidiennement par mail à ses membres
un mois avant
fait c'est la première fois face à cette
crise des institutions et me dire mais
en fait pour nous les siens la vidéo on
a un sentiment d'impuissance des colères
aussi trouve c'est difficile de voir des
personnes en train de se détruire
et apparemment il ya des jeunes des
mineurs qui sont actuellement
ces prostituées
toujours et je trouve que c'est un
scandale de toute façon n'aurait pas
laissé ses enfants en fait parce
qu'elles sont sont les croire
- sunrise ont besoin d'autres ce n'est
pas fini elle se dégrade de change
surtout après la prière constante ou
d'avoir le paris d'aujourd'hui ils sont
très dangereux parce que les caméras
sont là
le résultat ne les voit jamais et même
retourné l'appel je ne déplace pas parce
que je crois que mais michelin
en fait on se sent abandonnés par les
autorités mais les flyers pendant la
police je pense parce que de fait les
autorités laissent les cracks et vivre
dans la rue toute la journée même si
beaucoup ont diversement maintenant et
on en redemande à moi c'est que l'espace
public
la rue et les jardins soient se réserver
pour tout le monde je pense qu'il
faudrait aider les gens à sortir de
l'addiction et non pas les laisser dans
la maison
apparemment c'est la seule solution
interne on s'est écrit mais notre colère
il sait ce qui s'est passé jeudi
et c'est bien là je pense que c'est la
mobilisation était plus âgé ou fait ces
situations qui
non c'était difficile pour nous les
choses qui arrivent et ici on est 18e et
19e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]